today i found out that i was on a
samsung ad by accident
oh yeah oh yeah no yeah i saw
you sent another clip to sydney right uh
no no i didn't i didn't i uh
i saw you retweeting it i'm pretty sure
all right
i don't know i i i was here for your
fiverr thing so i did a fiverr video
where i became a fiver seller and
normally right five of you get like
vastly under charge and it's kind of
like that's kind of how the
website works right um but i got contact
by someone who was like
oh let's do uh an actual ad i thought
great this is amazing content for the
video because i can actually show people
like how to do it my feels yeah right i
was like oh flex
yeah and i i asked them a few questions
because normally
when you do a commercial with voice
acting you need to figure out uh it's
like buyout fees and depending on
basically how much the ad is going to
play and how many countries it's going
to play in is how you like calculate a
buyout fee so
the normal studio fee which is like the
doing the work and then there's the fee
for essentially using your voice
worldwide yeah and
you know the it varies a lot like you
can
i know dudes who have gotten like 50k
yeah
i mean you were talking about like in a
previous podcast episode about the guy
who does the ads for mcdonald's
yeah he lives off just that yeah and
like i i did a commercial one time where
i got like
eight thousand dollars for just one hour
of work was that the boats one
uh which one was that it was a car one
i'll have to find it i can get the link
you did that you did like a shaving one
as well all right yeah i've done a
shaving one on the passenger side
or whatever the [ __ ] it was yeah ages
ago and uh basically you get paid like
quite a lot for doing these
um and it's like okay cool
right nice nice and i thought okay this
commercial seems kind of small you know
it's like
this guy so how much did he pay you i
actually i asked because i thought this
ad was like pathetic yeah right
i asked for three hundred dollars oh
cause i was like ah it's only gonna take
like 30 minutes you you were thinking of
the content
that was what that was what was on your
mind i didn't want to be too greedy and
i really wanted to get it so yeah
300 is a normal like studio raid fee
plus like whatever it's only going to
play on the internet it's not a big deal
and then i actually had to do like
dubbing like actual mouth dabbing
oh yeah so you actually had to dub out
the entire scene yeah so i dubbed over
the dudes i didn't actually see the ad i
just saw you like
retweeting it or tweeting about it weird
i don't think my voice fits the dude
that well
it was so weird watching it because i
was watching the ad and i didn't know
what the process was
but what it felt like was remember
watching like those old hong kong movies
where he was like
badly dubbed lip flops over like the
over the film
like some kung pao yeah yeah exactly
that's what it
was yeah it's not bad i mean i mean
he was still saying what you were saying
yeah yeah yeah it just i think the
problem is is that like
uh especially because everyone knows my
voice yeah the problem is is that like
everyone knows my voice and that's not
what you hear when you hear my voice
yeah yeah yeah yeah
normally if you know you don't really
know the person you know
90 people are gonna hear that ad aren't
gonna be like oh yeah that's a normal
act yeah no biggie but people who know
me and be like what the [ __ ]
like what because it was so weird
hearing your voice
come out of like a really old man or
something like that i've done that
before
though like that's really like normal so
it was like legit samsung
it's like a samsung ad yeah yeah i don't
know what it's for but
[ __ ] like [ __ ] ripped off
again i mean i priced what i thought was
fair based on what the seller had told
me
yeah and if i knew it was going to be
samsung and it's going to be played
worldwide like that
you thought you thought you were playing
them but in the end they were playing
yeah
yeah they played so what the [ __ ] is
samsung hiring fiverr voice actors what
the [ __ ] yeah they're like go to like
professional
yeah it's a little not to say that you
know some voices
like professionals hearing more stories
makes me wonder how many how many big
industry companies are like going on
these small sites you know like
hiring fiverr voice actors going like
putting job ads on craigslist
i think or whatever yeah i think right
raylynn
without her so what i think happens is
that okay so samsung is there like
listen guys we have a genius
advertisement here we want a company to
handle it they go and find an ad agency
and then that agency is like we know
just the guy they probably hire another
agency
who then probably hires the final agency
that actually makes it yeah
and then they've got like no budget so
they're like get the five voice actors
because i'm not gonna lie a lot of the
five voice actors are really [ __ ]
good yeah yeah
they're getting charged like nothing
yeah um i mean i would argue that like
almost everyone on that website is
probably a little too overqualified for
what you're
i mean i mean they're either how the
website works yeah i mean they're either
overly qualified or they're heavily
underqualified
and there's no in-between there'll be
there'll be people with like a blue yeti
that are like
yeah i guess i can give you the
commercial rights to it
you know the you know 50 more words
gonna run you ah dude it's 400 bucks man
yeah yeah
it's like what what the [ __ ] i've had
that with like artists as well
yeah some of them are just like [ __ ]
god here where it's like you should make
an art book and then other people are
like
just started deviantart two days ago
let's go
100 per commission yeah let's go and
it's it's such a coin flip because
even if they have like a good portfolio
right i've had experiences where i've
hired like artists
uh to produce like artwork or music or
something yeah and
it is not up to the level they put on
their portfolio
exactly you can tell it was like here's
my a-list work
and you're just getting the d-list work
on fiverr here you know what i mean
because you're not paying me like 500
or some [ __ ] same with the the voice
acting as well because a lot of people
get their
demos done in a studio like fully like
mixed
produced professionally yeah than that
but then they do it at home
look at the [ __ ] blue yeti shut up in
a hotel room and it's like all
[ __ ] right don't know if this is what i
paid for you know like
see that's how i got [ __ ] scammed i
don't know hey i didn't get scammed it's
my bad like yeah yeah what well played
samsung yeah
so did you did you record this
commercial
shoot or commercial recording in your
own room yeah yeah okay
and i did it like i uh i didn't do any
of the treating actually because they
wanted to do it so
it was pretty painless the only thing
was that like because the lip flaps they
had like [ __ ] of course they zoomed
in on this man's [ __ ] face
so the lip flaps were so pronounced so
you could see exactly which syllable and
which
letter he was on yeah so and there was
one where they sent me
where they were like hey can you change
the script on this one line i'm like
no the man's lips say this thing what do
you mean can i change the script i can't
[ __ ] change it to what you
you've added in like three more words
how do you think i'm gonna do that
you should have done it just really like
drive home to like the kung pao element
of it right
now just sense it have been like this is
what you wanted this is what you asked
for this
is 300 bucks by the way
that would have been hilarious yeah it's
like it's like the lip flaps clearly say
like i love samsung but you just change
it to like buy apple
because it's it's like the next level
from anime dubbing right because without
any doubt it's so much harder than
anime dubbing you have to match all like
the lip flaps with the
same amount of scissors no three frames
actually yeah
i know this because i have to edit lip
flaps in the bridging right
in a bridging it's easy because you take
you take your script and you just
[ __ ] edit these three frames of mouth
it's closed mouth half open
and fully open yeah um but with dubbing
you obviously
can't edit the lip flaps or anything
like that so you just sometimes you hear
some lines and it's really it's a really
unnatural line
but you just you just gotta match what
the animation is
right yeah it's really like makes you
especially if you try and do it
really makes you [ __ ] appreciate
these like in the countries where they
mainly dub a lot of the
media that they import like how [ __ ]
insane that is that they managed to do
like
full seasons of shows yeah and like it's
not
terrible it's so hard because you're so
constrained with other mouth shapes
because you know i mean you have to
exactly copy it and luckily this was
english but like oh my god
meanwhile you have countries like japan
that are just like [ __ ] that yeah a lot
of it yeah
i've noticed japan is just like [ __ ] the
lip flaps let's just talk over here
like a million times more hilarious like
the voices the change in the voices is
already hilarious but then seeing
them like say something that's just not
a single mouth movement
you almost like don't mind it though
because you realize that they're just
like you they've not they're not trying
to do that yeah yeah it's like
it's like whatever man i was watching
like [ __ ] some
[ __ ] like history channel car
restoration show on tv
and they had like it was like a really
like old british guy and they had like
the proper like samurai sounding old
dude
and i was like wow okay jeez that's
somebody i don't think that's what he
sounds
that's what the old dude sound like in
japanese
oh